there is a scene
that i would love
the audience to see that i didn't put in
not because anyone asked me to cut it
but because i didn't think that within
the larger narrative it worked that it
was necessary but it's a really cool
scene with that same unseen prisoner in
arkham there was an earlier scene where
batman because he's getting these cards
and letters from the riddler and he's
thinking why is this guy writing to me
i'm supposed to be anonymous and he's
putting a lens on me i don't like that
and so he goes to kind of profile this
kind of serial killer and you see him
meeting with somebody who's obviously a
serial killer himself who because it's
not batman's origin but it is the
origins of all these other characters
you're seeing a version of this
character who yes when you see the
unknown prisoner you're like well gee i
think that's who that is well that is
who that is but he's not yet that
character this was a really cool scene
and what barry and what rob did in that
scene was super cool so at some point i
definitely want the audience to see that
scene just because they could see this
really cool scene but it isn't something
that's part of the overall narrative
that is like oh i wish i i won't even
put it in the movie it won't be a
different cut the cut that is out there
in the theaters that's the cut
is that scene do you think could it be
on the blu-ray or
yeah i mean we'll do something with it
we're gonna we're i mean look we've just
finished the movie we're now promoting
the movie we're figuring out what's
gonna happen when everything goes into
the sort of you know the home video
version of it um but there's definitely
a plan to do something with it we for
sure will show that scene
you